what up guys welcome to the just pearly
banks youtube channel
today we are going to be talking about
an interesting topic we're going to be
talking about age gap
marriages do they work um
i thought of this because kevin samuels
is like a big fan of age gap marriages
um i kept thinking like what would you
have in common
of your 50s with a 25 year old girl half
your age
so i was just curious if
that seems to work out so before i start
don't forget subscribe to the channel
i'm trying to 20 000 subscribers from
bring that notification bell also i'm
gonna be eating popcorn
i'm sorry so this is
an article i found it from 2014 from
market watch
which i found to be a more reliable
source but you know
if you guys don't think it's robot
liable let me know in the comments but
i've like found it to be pretty
reliable just like when i was in school
and stuff
um it talks about
um there are many early indications of
what might cause a marriage to crumble
before the couple walks up down the
aisle
and the age gap between partners is one
of them according to data in the recent
study of 3 000 people
um by andrew francis and hugo milan so 3
000 isn't like huge
um but it's not like
i would say it's still statistically
significant right
um
uh okay a fourth year
year science um graduate research
assistant from emory
found that the larger gap is related to
a higher divorce rate
so this is actually interesting because
i thought five years is kind of like the
perfect
like what people want well if you have a
five year age gap you're eighteen
percent more likely to get divorced
versus three percent with just a one
year age difference so
this is interesting because i know that
women typically like guys that are about
five years older
ten years older but a ten year age
difference
is thirty nine percent more likely and
ninety five percent more likely with a
twenty year age gap
um partners from different generations
may have different cultural reference
points and values and polar opposite
tastes in music and film
and even friends and also different
approaches to sex life
um sex drive goes up for women in middle
age but sexual function decreases for
men
so i don't know this is interesting
because kevin samuels is very much like
into like data and statistics but
he always is recommending that
people do the age gap thing
having your first child out of wedlock
statistically means you're 59
less wait
having your first child out of wedlock
statistically means you're 59
less likely to have a divorce wait less
likely what
um having a child during a marriage when
you're 76 percent
more likely to split that doesn't seem
right
oh
but that could also mean that happier
couples have more children
i would have guessed this you're 49 more
likely to divorce if you have different
levels of education than a couple with
the same level that makes sense because
i think women tend to divorce their
husbands if they're less educated or
they make less money i'm sure there's
some correlation
with that
um you're 49
less likely to divorce if you stay
together for two years
what you're 95. four percent less likely
to divorce if you reach tenure yeah okay
that makes sense
huh no children
so you're more likely to divorce if you
don't have children than if you do
oh i think i misread this so it looks
like
if you have your first child in wedlock
your least
likely i must have misread something
i don't know this is just an interesting
study it's kind of old so
i don't know if you guys would consider
it still relevant today but let me know
if you have any more stats and like
numbers on age gap dating
um because i have a hard time believing
that's like the best option just because
my parents
are fairly close in age like what five
years
um i've just noticed when girls date a
lot older
they are a lot of times interested in
the same things but let me know in the
comments if you guys agree or disagree
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell i'll talk to
you guys
next time